VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: Welcome
to "Cloud OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
I'm Vinnie Wienczorkowski
and today we're
going to talk about
GCP for G Suite users.
We're hosting these live
webinars every Tuesday.
Throughout the talk, you can
enter questions in the platform
below, and Googlers will
be standing by to answer.
At the end of the
talk, we're going
to choose some of your questions
to answer during live Q&A.
With that said, let's get
started with the presentation.
As I mentioned, my name
is Vincent Wienczorkowski
and I'm a Cloud Sales Manager.
I've been working for
the past seven years
with helping customers
or clients onboard
to various cloud platforms.
NICK PAN: Hey, guys.
My name is Nick Pan.
I'm a Cloud Customer
Engineer that
works on the Google Cloud team.
I've been working with a lot of
customers as well as business
leaders and developers
on determining the best
way to host applications
on Google Cloud.
Super excited to be here
today and to talk to you
about how you can use Google
Cloud to empower your G Suite
users.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So in terms of--
thematically, what
we hope to do is
talk a little bit about how
we're engaging with customers.
We're going to do
a couple demos,
and we're also going
to talk about some case
studies and some differentiators
and how customers are actually
using Google technology
to innovate--
[AUDIO OUT]---- merging various
aspects of Google Cloud to meet
you where you're at
and help you innovate.
It doesn't mean you
have to lift and shift
or move your entire
infrastructure,
even though that's
a way of working
with some of our customers.
But it's leveraging
things like APIs,
it's bridging some of
our platform services,
and in a lot of cases, it's how
can we meet you where you're at
and be able to provide value?
So when we talked about
Google Cloud Platform,
one of the most important
things to talk about
is the scale we actually bring.
And one of the things
that demonstrates
scale is, you're already
working with Google
and some of the G Suite
Platform services we provide.
And a thing to note, and--
those same services or the
same scales available for you
to build on top of is powering
over seven products that have
over one billion users each.
So in sense of how we're making
investments in the platform,
over the past three years,
we've invested not only capital,
but we have partner
advancements,
we have new regions
standing up, and we
have innovations in
terms of creating
commercialized versions
of Google tech that
has made us successful.
So when we talked about,
it's not just spinning disk,
it's whether you want to
leverage us for an API
to build in a creative value
to your current environment
or whether it's building
that globally-distributed
application, we're
engaging customers
on a lot of different levels.
So when we talked about
Google Cloud as a whole,
there are a lot of different
ways of working with customers.
We're going to talk
about GCP today,
but all of you on
the live broadcast
are very familiar
with G Suite services.
Some of those same
capabilities in terms
of building
globally-distributed storage
systems in collaboration,
those capabilities
are available for
you to integrate
into your applications,
but GCP as a whole
has a very deep and broad
capability of portfolio,
and we're certainly engaged
in customers in anything
from moving entire data centers,
or just providing access
to our API so they
can build those
into their existing
applications and services.
So when we take
a high level look
at just the tiers of
services that we're offering,
many people may not
be aware, but when
it comes to business platforms
such as Apigee or Orbitera,
who are leveraging some of our
APIs, what we've been leaning
into or making sure
that we make available
is the ability for customers
not to have to move
any of their infrastructure.
How can we create an environment
that's going to provide value?
Apigee, managing or
monetizing your API business,
Orbitera, providing some
SAS platform offerings
to you-- leveraging our
APIs to actually integrate
into your existing applications.
The other thing we have been
seeing in the marketplace
or with our customers is,
customers want a variety
of offerings-- anything from
analytics and machine learning,
which is certainly an area
that can stand alone--
but they also want to build and
deploy applications, and not
have to worry about that
undifferentiated heavy lifting
of managing infrastructure.
So with things like App Engine
and Container Engine, areas
where you can deploy and build
applications on a global scale
without having to manage
the base storage and VMs.
With that said, we're also
going to talk about some
of the core infrastructure,
storage, and networking
components that
certainly are interesting
and, we believe, provide
some differentiators-- again,
building a global infrastructure
or the business value.
So right now, what
I'm going to do--
I'm going to have Nick talk
about security, networking,
and infrastructure, and
talk a little bit about some
of the core differentiators that
we have on our base platform.
NICK PAN: Hey, Vinnie, thanks
so much for that overview.
Let's dig a little
bit deeper into things
that surround security,
networking, and infrastructure
on Google Cloud.
And we'll hopefully uncover some
of the secret sauce that really
makes Google Cloud a
very novel platform
to host your infrastructure on.
We believe that we have an
excellence in reliability.
We have unparalleled speed
and scalability in 2018
for a total of 15
regions globally.
And we have four more that
are being announced in 2018.
Across the board,
we believe that we
have state of the art
infrastructure and unparalleled
performance, and we will allude
to this in the further slides
on this presentation.
So digging deep into what
we often tell customers.
In the industry,
we often hear users
saying that they want to
lift and shift to the cloud.
But at Google, we actually
use the term lift and improve.
The reason why I want
to say lift and improve
is because, as you start
using these cloud-native
technologies, as you start
embracing some of these higher
level services and
APIs, you're actually
able to improve your
overall business model
and accelerate your business and
transform your IT department.
We have one really
awesome feature
known as live migration,
and that's the ability
to basically move
virtual machines
from one underlying host
to another underlying host.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: So,
Nick, from a live migration,
it seems like an
interesting feature.
But how, operationally,
is that really
going to change the
way I'm doing business?
How is that going to impact
our customers to improve
upon what they're doing?
NICK PAN: Well, that's
a really great question.
In terms of the
start of the year,
I'm sure many of
you in the audience
have heard of the CPU
vulnerabilities that
occurred in January--
Meltdown and Spectre.
These were CPU
vulnerabilities where
there was a very high severity
and a very business critical
need to patch your
CPUs and make sure
that we reduce the risk of the
security as much as possible.
With live migration,
Google Cloud
was actually able to patch
all of our underlying fleet
without our customers actually
noticing any sort of downtime
or patching done
to those instances.
So as you start using
Google Cloud's technology,
you inherit all
of these benefits
and employ a very
secure security posture.
Also, we have a very customer
friendly pricing model.
So we have features such as
sustained use discounts, which
are automatic discounts
on our virtual machines
as you use them.
And generally, we
see customers who
are using Google Cloud
Platform to save around
30% on virtual machines
a month, just based off
of using those automatic
sustained use discounts.
We also have the idea of
custom machine types, which
are the ability to fine
tune your configuration
of your virtual machines
in terms of number of CPUs
as well as gigabytes
of RAM in order
to really cater your
machine shapes to meet
the needs of your applications.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So, Nick,
that's interesting just from a
more flexible business model.
But what does that actually
mean for a retail customer
or somebody in media and
how sustained use discounts
and custom machine types
can impact their business
operations and affect
their bottom line?
NICK PAN: So in terms
of in industries,
when you think about things like
using cloud for burst capacity,
often times you're not
actually committing
to a particular instance
type or a reservation
in terms of pulls of compute.
With that, you're actually
able to have sustained
use discounts automatically
applied to that burst capacity,
and have real time
discounts based off
of those fluctuations of
usage for your applications.
Additionally, for our customers
who are looking to lift
and improve-- not
lift and shift--
we actually see them not
understanding, really,
how the cloud works
yet, but they're
able to benefit from
sustained usage discounts
because they're not
having to commit
to anything at that
point, and they're just
inheriting that sustained
use discount as they ramp up.
So overall, increasing
agility, having a more customer
friendly business
model, and ensuring
that we're giving all the
controls to the customer
to make sure you're
making the right choices
in terms of price, as
well as performance.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: So
basically, true cloud economics
and no guesswork in
how to get discounting.
NICK PAN: Exactly.
And we believe that the bread
and butter of Google Cloud that
makes this so powerful
is our underlying global
infrastructure.
If you look at this
slide, we could
see that this is our
global footprint.
As I said before, 15 regions.
We maintain one of the largest
backbones on the internet
currently.
Statistics show
from third parties
that we probably have around 30%
of the world's internet traffic
pass through our backbone
on any given day.
And what this empowers
you as a developer or you
as a business leader is being
able to harness this network
to host your applications
either closer to your users
or to reduce latency,
as well as the overall
hops that it takes
to reach your users,
as well as have system
to system traffic.
So very powerful for increasing
that network throughput
and that network bandwidth.
And we really believe
Google Cloud is a place
to build multi-regional,
globally distributed
systems on the cloud.
And this really shows
you where the rubber
meets the road,
where it actually
shows you instances doing
network diagnostic tests
between two regions.
So I went ahead and spun up
a virtual machine in Oregon,
as well as a virtual
machine in Japan,
and did a ping as
well as a traceroute
across, bi-directionally
from those instances.
If you could see on the bottom,
there is actually only one hop
that it traverses when
it goes between our VMs.
And the reasons for that is
because we operate our network
backbone, and we're able
to hold onto that traffic
for a majority of the route and
ensure that you have a secure,
consistent, as well
as reliable route
as you pass through the
internet on our backbone.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So, Nick, what I'm saying
is, whether or not you
are building an isolated
application in
one of our regions
or building a
distributed application
in multiple regions,
you're going
to benefit from
staying on our backbone
from a security and a
consistent performance
from a networks standpoint.
Is that right?
NICK PAN: Exactly.
So we don't have to actually
push traffic to a transit ISP
or transit provider.
We operate our backbone
and are able to ensure
that performance.
And along with all
of this, we believe
that we very much excel in
security across the board
at Google Cloud.
So we employ a defense in depth
at scale by default posture.
So from the hardware
level in terms
of the actual infrastructure to
the actual higher levels, which
are things like operational
and device security,
we ensure that we have all
those checkboxes checked,
and we're making sure that you
embrace that security model
that we bring to the table.
One of the differentiators at
Google Cloud is that we ensure
that data-- things like pushing
objects to object storage
and things of that sorts--
are all encrypted
by default. We want
to make sure that
your data is secure,
and we want to make sure
that we're setting you
guys up for success when you
leverage our tools as well
as our products.
Another thing is
that we actually
manufacture a lot of our
hardware, and a lot of it
is purpose built for our needs.
And this leads to
better performance
as well as reducing
the chance of vendor
in the middle risks, when you're
actually procuring peripherals
from other vendors.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So, Nick,
a couple of things I see from
that, because we get asked
about encryption all the time.
So certainly on top of
Google, since everything
is encrypted at default, it's
not left up to the operator,
so you're ensuring
that all of your data
is encrypted all of the time.
So from an operations
standpoint,
there's an efficiency there.
But I also see from a
performance standpoint,
if you're taking a
look at a VM, certainly
encryption is overhead
to infrastructure.
If that's already baked
into our infrastructure,
your inherent value
and cost associated
with that is already included.
So you have
security, operations,
and cost efficiencies.
What if somebody wants to
bring in their own keys
and wants to manage keys
on top of that encryption?
What do we do then?
NICK PAN: So we have
offerings that allow customers
to bring their own keys.
So they're called
customer managed keys.
They integrate with
many of our services.
And we also have a
key management service
for if you want to have
an actual managed KMS that
can do things like rotate keys,
set a key expiration policy,
and things of that sorts.
And in terms of certifications
for third party audits as well
as accreditations, we are
checked off across the board.
These are just to name a few.
We have a page on our website
Cloud.Google.com/security that
breaks down all of these
accreditations as well
as different white papers that
really drill home what happens
under the hood at Google to
ensure that our platform is
safe and secure.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
Excellent.
So certainly all of
that's good information.
But, you know, I think
when it comes down to it,
it's all about our
customers and the impression
that they get in
working with Google
and also leveraging
our technology.
And instead of us
telling the story,
it's always good to
take a look at what
some of the people who have
decided to move onto GCP
and leverage our
services are saying.
So Etsy is actually a
good example of somebody
who is going through
a transformation
and trying to concentrate
on providing value
to their customers, and not
have to worry about managing
spinning disk or data centers.
So if you take a look at
what Mike Fisher, Etsy's CTO,
has said about
working with Google,
it wasn't just about
the technology.
It wasn't just about
the machine learning.
It was also about working with
Google engineers directly, as
well as our professional
services, as well
as our engagement team.
So there are a lot
of factors that
come into selecting
the right provider.
And I think if you actually take
a look at what Mike has done
in terms of doing
product selection--
there's a link that
we'll provide--
there's really a
comprehensive look as to,
it's not just about what
technology is available today
and the capabilities, but
it's also looking about,
how you are looking to grow
in the future, both regionally
as well as globally.
So a lot of people out
there are listening,
and certainly Etsy is
a large environment.
But certainly, I
wouldn't expect everybody
ready to just drop
their entire data center
or move from an existing
cloud provider to us.
What if somebody
wanted to get started
with a simple, one VM move?
How can we help them do that?
Is there something we can
kind of demonstrate for them?
NICK PAN: Yeah.
So I put together a
demo where it basically
goes through one
of our tools that
are baked into our platform.
We built this in partnership
with CloudEndure,
and it's basically
a built in VM import
that allows you to
move a virtual machine
from either on-premises
or another cloud
into Google Cloud Platform,
completely managed.
So if you see in
this demo, we're
walking through what the
overall workflow looks like.
But high-level
what it does as you
go through installation
of agents on the VM
that you're trying to migrate
as well as the target VM that's
within Google
Cloud Platform, you
select, like, a VM
shape or a configuration
for that virtual machine,
and then an actual agent
begins a continuous
replication between that source
and that target.
Once replication
is finished, you
have that target
instance that is
a complete mirror of
your source that's either
on premises or another
cloud, and you could easily
provide some testing,
and then do a cut over.
And what this allows you to do
is have a completely managed
solution that allows you to
move your virtual machines
from another area
into the cloud.
And then the kicker is
that it's completely free.
So we cover all the costs
and it's provided to you
as an added service to
our Google Compute Engine
service, which is our virtual
machines or infrastructure
as a service tool.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: Great.
So that's interesting
because it looks
like we're using a partner and
a partner technology on how
to actually get started.
What's interesting
about that is,
it's a tool and a service
that's already built in.
And it's some additional value
that we're actually providing.
How do you get
out of the screen?
How do you get out?
NICK PAN: [INAUDIBLE].
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
All right.
So I guess the next thing
that we want to talk about
is some additional
customer examples.
So if you take a look at
folks that are moving to us,
we talked about Etsy.
One of the things that
we do want to talk about
is QuantConnect, who is another
great example of somebody
leveraging Google
Cloud Platform.
They started out
as a G Suite user.
They actually were leveraging
another cloud provider.
And what they were
looking for was
better efficiency,
better reliability,
as well some overall business
value or cost savings.
And if you take a look
at the number of products
they're using, they
definitely lean
in a lot using Container
Engine as well as Cloud SQL.
So they're really
taking advantage
of not only the
platform services,
but some of the
inherent business value.
The nice part
about this use case
is, they were able to
get better reliability
and also drive some significant
value from a business value
cost savings.
So reliability as
well as remaining
and keeping a flat
cost while increasing
their business by 6x.
Pretty impressive.
At the beginning
of the presentation
or the conversation, we talked
about our serverless strategy.
So it's not just
about spinning disk.
It's not just about
leveraging our APIs,
but certainly serverless
is one of the areas where
a lot of folks are leaning
in and supporting their cloud
strategy.
What's interesting
about this is,
Google actually started
out in the serverless space
with our App Engine product.
And Nick Rockwell,
who's actually
a very interesting person
in the cloud industry,
is actually leveraging
a multicloud strategy.
And where he has leaned
into Google Cloud
is in the serverless
area, where he's
leveraging App Engine and
other serverless capabilities
to actually accelerate
and not worry
about managing spinning
disk or object storage.
He's definitely
leaning into supporting
the overall value of getting
applications out to customers
faster.
NICK PAN: So we've covered
a lot of technology.
I've thrown a lot of
terms at you folks.
We know that a lot of you
guys are already using G Suite
or are G Suite administrators.
And here's a simple
use case for how
you could use some of these
Google Cloud technologies
to improve your business.
Within G Suite,
there's a lot of logs
that are output to your G
Suite administrator dashboard,
as well as a lot of
audit trails that you
could use to draw meaningful
insights for your business.
You could easily take
that data and move it
into our data warehouse
known as BigQuery,
and draw meaningful
dashboards using
a tool known as Data Studio.
So you see on this
slide, there's
this G Suite Insights page.
And you're able to easily create
these nice dashboards that
allow you to look
at things like,
how are my docs usage
across my organization.
How is my collaboration?
How many hours of--
how many hours of GBC we had
throughout the presentation,
or throughout our organization?
So being able to
easily determine
a lot of awesome insights
from using these tools
is what drives value
to you as a customer.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So I'm seeing
building a single pane
of glass, whether it's
G Suite log information
or information from things
like Google Analytics
or DoubleClick.
There are a lot of use
cases where customers
are building a
single pane of glass
using BigQuery as that engine.
NICK PAN: Awesome.
Yep.
And there's a lot
of integrations
between our different services.
So this is a quick
demo that I created
that allowed you to be able to
query sheets from your BigQuery
engine.
And we're going to walk
through this real quick.
So to access the
console, you go ahead
and go to
Console.Cloud.Google.com.
And from there, you're able
to actually go ahead and use
BigQuery as your execution
engine to query data sets
within Sheets.
So within here you
could see that you
could pull a Google
Drive file, which
can be a sheet that specified
in your particular drive.
And then from there,
this particular demo,
we're going to go ahead and
analyze Black Friday market
sales data within our sheet.
So here you could
see that there's
things like the
items that were sold,
the cost of those
particular items,
as well as meaningful
information
for this particular spreadsheet.
You can easily pull
us into BigQuery,
and then run queries against
it using standard SQL syntax.
And what is great about this
is that you can basically
use BigQuery to query
very, very large data
sets that might be larger than
what's available in Sheets,
and move forwards
from there and provide
accessibility to this
tool with your data
analyst by just creating
users, and inviting them
to your project.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So just as an end user,
what it looks like to me is
where turbocharging Sheets,
to kind of extend it into
tremendous scaling capabilities
to get information in and out,
whether it's leveraging Sheets
as that data source, or
potentially exporting data
from this petabyte scale engine.
NICK PAN: Exactly.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So one of the ways
that we talked about earlier
is leveraging Google APIs.
How can our customers
work with us,
without changing any of the
underlying infrastructure?
And one of the
things that customers
are working with us on is,
certainly from a BigQuery
standpoint, for data analytics.
But the other area
is machine learning.
Machine learning is
certainly a topic or an area
that Google has been
leveraging within a whole array
of products.
And if you take a look
at all the products
we've got displayed, we've
been incorporating machine
learning capabilities
and features that you
might be familiar with--
things like data loss prevention
in G Suite in the Enterprise
version, things
like in Photos where
you can categorize
by somebody's face,
or the actual event
that's happening,
things like in Translate
where we're actually
using advanced machine
learning techniques
to get better and better
translation capabilities.
A lot of these servicers or
APIs are now available for you.
And the nice part
about it is, you
don't need to change where
your infrastructure is.
It can provide immediate value.
One of the things we
talk to customers on,
based on their journey
is, they might have
moved to a secondary provider.
They might be on-prem.
You might not be ready to move.
But if we can bring
value now, it's
an important part of
leveraging Google tech,
and leveraging us
for their technology,
or their innovation journey.
So one of the great
examples of [INAUDIBLE]
to do a better correlation or
matching for their recruitment
efforts.
What they're able to get
is significant improvements
in the click-throughs
on the career sites,
based on the searches
people are doing,
as well as the quality
of the applications.
So we have a number of folks,
whether it's a platform service
provider or an
enterprise customer,
who is just using something
as simple as our Jobs API
to help them innovate, or help
them do things differently.
Another great example of
innovation and leaning
to customers to help
them categorize and drive
additional revenues is Hearst.
Hearst has been leveraging our
natural language processing
API, which allows them
to get better contextual
awareness on what
conversations are being had.
What is of interest
to their customers?
So we've been enabling them
via the natural language
parsing API, as well as leaning
into engines like BigQuery.
All in all, what it
allows them to do
is personalize user experiences
and hopefully derive
additional revenue long term.
So it's certainly driving
business value, as well as
an innovation.
NICK PAN: So hey, Vinnie.
In terms of across
the publishing space,
are there other
machine learning APIs
that you see customers
often using for publishing?
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: Sure,
that's a great question.
A lot of customers
on the first use case
are leveraging our Vision
API or our Video API,
for doing dynamic meta tech.
So there are a lot of ways that
we can certainly start, again,
with something as
simple as an API.
And then often as we
progress with a customer,
we might get into
different discussions,
and even get into
things like Apigee,
or even infrastructure play.
So it's really about where
can we help customers now,
and provide value immediately.
So in terms of getting
started with GCP,
there are a lot of ways you
can get started with us.
We certainly are
working with people
in many areas of their
cloud or technology
journey for innovation,
or just learning.
Analytics and big
data-- consolidating
all the analytics, so
then you can potentially
apply machine learning
capabilities on top of it,
or to just get that
single pane of glass
that we talked about from a
advertising single pane glass,
or just some log files.
NICK PAN: So in my
opinion, the easiest way
to get started
with Google Cloud,
if you're just trying to
start to use it as a platform,
is you have a hobby project.
You have a blog, try to create
that blog and Google Compute
Engine and try to scale it out
as you need, as traffic grows.
But across the board, it's
very easy to get started, and--
[INAUDIBLE]
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
[INAUDIBLE] Test data,
using [INAUDIBLE]
data archiving,
or even [? HPC ?]
workloads, which
are very bursty in nature,
the speed of performance--
that global networking that we
talked about, the global scale.
And also the fact that from
a business value standpoint,
you're cheating
those usage based,
or those automatic
discounting constructs,
to truly make it cloudy, or
have cloud economics, as opposed
to restricting people
based on their ability
to run things 24/7, which
is really not a cloud model.
So resources.
So we'd love if
everybody on this call
reaches out and
connects with us,
and we can actually
have discussions
with everybody on
the line right now,
or everybody on the webcast.
The best way to get in
touch with your Google Cloud
technical resources, or
Cloud sales managers,
is to just go to
cloud.google.com/contact,
fill out a form,
we'll reach you out.
If you're already
in touch with us,
we'd love to have some deeper
conversations with you.
Another great resource, if you
don't want to reach out to us,
but you want to keep up to
date with what's going on
with the Cloud Platform,
and all the new innovations
with the new regions,
is to apply or register
for our newsletter.
A really great way
to keep up to date
with all of the new things,
or even the new platforms,
or the use cases
that were actually
coming out from architectural
recommendations.
From a training
standpoint, there
are a lot of ways that
customers can directly
get training, or learn
about our platform.
There's Qwiklabs, which
are interactive labs that
will showcase how to do
anything from standing up a VM,
all the way down to machine
learning, and leveraging
BigQuery.
There's on-demand training,
or online training forces
with Coursera.
That's more of a formalized
training, versus a lab.
We also have formalized
classroom training that you can
actually sign up for, if you go
to cloud.google.com/training.
But you can also reach out to
your Cloud account executive,
and we can certainly work with
you to tailor classes that
might fit more into your needs.
So we definitely want
to work with you.
The last thing that I
actually want to talk about
is, from an advancement
or engaging with Google,
there's a rich ecosystem
of partner capabilities.
Whether we have systems
integrators, large and small,
global in scale or regional
and agile, with specialties,
there are a lot
of ways that we've
been growing our
ecosystem, and you
can work with Google
partners directly,
Google professional services.
We'd love to hear
from you, and we'd
love to get a little bit more
on how we can help you implement
Google technology.
So in terms of getting started
today, we appreciate your time.
We'll be back in under a
minute, once we have a chance
to review some of the
questions that you've
been asking, hopefully,
in the last 30 minutes.
We'll select a few questions,
and we'll come back
and we'll hopefully give
you some good answers.
Thank you.
NICK PAN: Thanks.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
Hi, welcome back.
Again, Vinnie
Wienczorkowski, Nick Pan.
We've got five questions that
were asked from the audience.
And we're going to do
our best to answer them.
They're diverse in nature, but
we'll start from the bottom up,
instead of top down.
And the first question
is specifically
on health care industry and
building HIPAA-compliant
applications on top of GCP.
So Google Cloud Storage is one
of the services that's actually
built to be HIPAA compliant.
But in general, as an
overview, absolutely, Google
can build and deploy globally
distributed, or regionally
distributed HIPAA-compliant
applications.
In fact, we talked about
our Cervalis capabilities,
and recently--
I think about a week ago--
we announced that
App Engine is now
capable of providing
HIPAA-compliant applications.
So you can do anything from
store the content on Google
Cloud Storage.
You can build applications
from the ground up,
using our virtual machines.
Or you can build full
service applications
on top of App Engine.
NICK PAN: And to take
us a step further,
for customers who are
handling very sensitive data,
we have API such as the
Data Loss Prevention
API, which is actually
baked into G Suite as well.
So being able to see or analyze
a block of text, understanding
if there's things in there
that are sensitive in nature,
or things like social
security numbers,
things like user
identities, or things that
fall in the umbrella of PII.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: Great.
So the next question is about,
explain the low latency options
when we have customers that
operate in multiple regions--
how to decide where to
put, and cost estimates.
It's actually been a
pretty big question.
And I think we have to dig
into the specific use case.
But let's talk about
a couple of scenarios.
I think we covered
a lot of them.
And one of the benefits was
our global distributed network.
But what we didn't really drill
into is some of the services
that we've built,
that take advantage
of that network, that can be
built to potentially distribute
your application-- things
like our Google Cloud Storage.
You have the option,
on top of GCP,
to build in a regional
bucket, if you so choose.
But what you can
also do, is you can
build object storage
to do distribution
within a continent.
So you can actually have
a distributed workload.
I actually have one customer,
they're a media company.
And they do a lot
of transcoding.
And one of the things
that they need to do
is they need to
select infrastructure
in a very bursty nature.
The fact that they're able to
take advantage of our globally
distributed object storage
allows them to pull and spin up
transcoding resources,
potentially in the spot market,
from any of our regions
around the United States.
That doesn't limit them
from staying isolated
within the region.
Since they're talking
about video files,
once they transcode, they
drop it in object storage.
It's read after
write consistency,
and read after list consistency,
on a confident basis.
So again, distributed
compute, resources from a
where do I grab the VM from.
But the fact that we're actually
distributing the object storage
is really of value, that if
you look at other providers,
in some cases you have to
add tiers, or implement
additional layers of
services, in order
to accomplish the same thing.
NICK PAN: I totally agree.
This is a very
dimensional question.
So I kind of like in the
end of the presentation,
you have a sales rep, you
have a customer engineer.
So if you're
looking to architect
multi-regional deployments
on Google Cloud Platform,
definitely use those
channels of engagement
with the Google Cloud
team, to ensure you're
doing this the right way.
We have many white
papers that walk over
how to actually design
this, from the engineering
standpoint, and also many
services at [INAUDIBLE] that
can make sure that
we drive costs down.
And we design this then in
optimal fashion for your team.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So the next question is,
we talked about it's not
about spinning disks.
It's about helping customers
innovate using Google tech,
and everybody on online is
using G Suite to innovate.
You're going to hear in
a little bit about how
you can extend that, and use
Jamboard to create a better
meeting experience.
So we're going to
talk about that.
But in terms of not just
spinning disk on top of us,
I'd be remiss not to
mention, especially
based on the first question,
within the health care space.
Google is uniquely
positioned to not only allow
you to build your
HIPAA-compliant workloads
in a region, or
distributed across region,
but gaining access to
that HIPAA-compliant data.
Managing that end
user experiencing
in using Chrome as an
operating system, whether it's
a kiosk, whether it's
a tablet, whether it's
a Chromebook, to ensure
that you have end to end
HIPAA compliance and control--
it's not just about what's
in the back end or data
center for security,
but it's how
is that data being entered and
managed on those endpoints.
So we're uniquely
positioned to do that,
and we actually have quite a few
use cases where in health care,
Chrome and G Suite, and a
lot of other capabilities,
are marrying well into our
back end infrastructure.
NICK PAN: On the ball.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI: Great.
So I guess the next question
is about machine learning.
Maybe I'll let Nick
kind of pick this one,
is how are we working with
customers to implement and take
advantage of machine learning,
which Google certainly
has been leaning into from
TensorFlow, in our ML platform.
What are ways we're doing that?
NICK PAN: So across
the board we believe
that we have a leadership
in machine learning.
At Google Cloud we have
these pretrained machine
learning APIs, which
allow you to easily do
tasks such as use
computer vision
to extract meaningful
information from images.
Or use our Video
Intelligence API
to be able to pull out metadata,
or meaningful information,
from videos that
customers are trying
to ingest into some
sort of object storage.
We also released a
new service, known
as AutoML, which is
riding off of the message
from our CEO Sundar,
which is to democratize
AI for the general public.
And what democratized
AI means, is the fact
that there is not as
many data scientists
as are developers in the world.
So being able to
empower developers
with these machine
learning models
that we've trained in-house
at Google, based off
of running these data
sets through the data
sets that we have running
our production systems,
and empowering these developers
with these black box APIs,
that they can then
feed things into,
to be able to drive
meaningful insights from.
On the AutoML side,
we're basically
making it so that you could
actually ingest and tweak
these particular models to
meet more so to your data sets,
and go through it easy
GUI to be able to train
these models to meet
your tailored data sets.
So to take this a
step further, what
that means is that
the Vision API might
be able to recognize that
this image is a dog or a cat.
But then, if you were to train
this on a more deeper data
set, which is something
that you as a customer
brings to the table, you will
be able to actually recognize
like a species of the dog.
So maybe you will be able
to say this is not just
a dog, but a golden retriever.
Or this is not just a
dog, it is a poodle.
So across the board,
doing a lot of things
in machine learning space.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So I hear customization
without a lot of
the overhead that
often comes with customization.
That's super exciting,
and personally I'm
super jazzed about AutoML.
Just based on [AUDIO OUT]
mission of machine learning,
and leaning in with Google.
So lots of customers and easy
use cases to get started on.
The last part is, we talked
about API serverless technology
and infrastructure services.
What are my options for a
multi-vendor environment.
So that's certainly--
in a cloud journey,
people are saying they're all
in in one, but a lot of folks
are talking about, how can
I use the right platform
for the right workload.
How can I take advantage
of the cloud marketplace?
A lot of vendors in it.
So what are we doing there?
NICK PAN: So I mean in
terms of [INAUDIBLE],,
we have a cloud marketplace,
where you can actually
leverage the tool to be able to
organize with different vendors
and software.
In terms of having a
multi-vendor approach,
we're actually able to peel off
some of the services and tools
to also leverage some of
our higher level services.
So it's something really
key to drill in on,
is that we have a lot of
services at Google Cloud,
but it's a la carte.
So you could use
services as you need.
So if you're trying to use
something for data analytics,
if you want a very powerful
SQL execution engine,
you could go ahead
and just use BigQuery
to analyze your data sets.
If you're looking to just have
a website hosted in the cloud,
you could choose use
Google Compute Engine
to host your virtual machines.
There's a lot of really
interesting things
you could do with
Google Cloud Platform,
and understanding how
all these pieces fit
into overall picture,
that's what really
drives value for you as a user.
VINCENT WIENCZORKOWSKI:
So you know
what gets me excited about
multi-vendor environment,
I think with the proliferation
of containers and Kubernetes
as the fault scheduler.
I think the fact
that it was part
of Google's sponsorship of
that program to actually bring
that to bear is certainly
something that excited me,
as well as TensorFlow, and
some of the other open source
programs that will allow people
to build in the multicloud.
So we really appreciate
everybody's time.
That's all the time
we have for today.
Thanks for tuning
into "Cloud OnAir."
We're glad you joined us.
We're running these
webinars every Tuesday.
Stay tuned for the
next one, which
is going to be integrated or
better meetings, leveraging
some of our Jamboard technology.
Thank you.
NICK PAN: Thank you so much.